- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is
choose who you listen to.
Over to you, Gabrielle Union.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Early in my career, I was named
the next it girl.
And you're like, "Well, I think I should
"really believe this."
You know, and then you read,
"You're the worst thing ever,
"you should never leave the house."
And you're like, oh, we
should throw that out.
And eventually you just
kind of get to a place
where they kind of cancel each other out.
You're going to hear the naysayers
and the people who think you suck,
and there are going to
be the people who think
you're the second coming of pockets,
but it's usually somewhere in the middle.
If you believe all your
praise, there's nowhere to go,
you're not going to grow.
And if you believe every
negative thing about you,
you're not going to get out of bed.
So, I try to be reasonable.
People whose opinion I respect, I listen.
- You need to be really
careful who you listen to.
You've got this big dream,
you've got these big ambitions,
you want to make your mark,
you want to do your thing,
and often that's scary.
You know, if it involves doing something
you've never done before,
that can be quite scary,
and when people tell you
that you can't do it,
when people tell you that you suck,
when people tell you it's
never going to work out,
a lot of times that's really hard to hear
because you are doubting yourself.
And when you hear that from other people,
that just compounds the
doubt and makes you wonder,
can I actually go out an do this thing?
And so choosing who you listen to
is really, really important.
Some people will pour rain on your parade
because they're jealous,
because maybe they've taken their shot
at following their dreams
and it didn't work out,
and so now nobody around them
can have success either.
Nobody else is allowed to go off
and be an entrepreneur and
chase their dreams because
they tried it and it didn't work out,
and so nobody else can have it.
Life sucks, and they're going to drag
everybody down in the hole with them.
That's a lot of people.
Others may rain on your parade because
they actually love you.
They just don't see what you see.
You know, your parents may think that
it's not a great idea,
or your guidance
counselor, or your friends
may not think that what
you're doing is feasible,
because in their world,
nobody's ever done it,
because they haven't done it.
And your parents may be
thinking success equals this,
because that's what success is for them,
because that's the path that they took.
And so they may be raining on your parade,
but it's out of love,
it's not out of jealousy.
At the end of the day, they want
to see you become successful,
they just have a different
definition of success,
and they don't want to
see you go through pain,
and hurt, and struggle, and woes,
and maybe not reaching your goal.
And then there are other
people who will give you
the perfect advice, exactly what you need
exactly at the right
time that you need it.
And so, really pay attention
to who is giving this advice,
and not trying to have an
emotional reaction to it,
but look at that person.
Say, "Has this person
done what I want to do?
"Does this person have the expertise
"to give me the advice that I need?"
Because if somebody is telling you
that your idea sucks
and will never work out,
and they haven't done
what you are trying to do,
then their advice is meaningless to you.
If anything, you should do the opposite.
Why are you taking advice
from someone who hasn't done
what you want to do?
You cannot let their limiting mindset
prevent you from being great.
And it doesn't mean you
need to attack them.
It doesn't mean you need to say,
"You don't know what you're talking about!
"You have a limiting mindset!
"You've never gone out
and achieved your dreams!"
You don't have to hurt them back,
but you also don't have to react
to the information they're giving you.
Treat them like a child,
treat them like a puppy,
treat them like a baby.
They can't help it.
They're negative.
It may be out of jealousy,
it may be out of love,
but either way, you wouldn't
take advice from a baby.
And if you can diffuse that in your head,
if you can understand that these people
have not done what you're trying to do,
and not listen to their advice,
and not listen to their doubts,
and still know that you
need to get this done,
and maybe it doesn't work out,
maybe you don't hit that dream,
maybe you don't get your goals,
but you still need to know.
Because you would rather
fail and at least know
than live the rest of your life uncertain
and in regret, wishing you had gave more
to the cause to figure
out if it would work.
Stop planning, stop
thinking with the head,
stop using your logic all the time.
With all the big decisions,
make them with the heart.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious,
who has given you the best advice
for your business, and what was it?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Stefan Patak.
Thank you so much, man, for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope that you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- The only time in the last
couple of years that I knew,
as soon as we finished a song,
that it was sort of a, like,
I hate to say game changer,
but that it was sort of a
next level situation was
when I finished Shake It Off.
But I wanted to be sure, so I,
that was the very end of
the recording process.
I finished Shake It Off and I knew
I was done with the record,
and I flew back to Nashville,
had a bunch of label people who I trust,
and a bunch of management who I trust,
and my mom and dad sit in
my parents' living room,
and I played them the full record,
and I didn't tell them anything about
how I thought I had
written the first single.
I didn't tell them anything like,
"You got to listen, like,
listen for track eight.
"Shake It Off is the
one, I'm telling you."
But when that song came
on and halfway through,
all of them look at me
and go, "This is the one,"
it was such a validating feeling because
I thought I knew, and
I was so sure I knew,
and then it turned out I did know.